we read an email at the end of the show
we answer the email segment is called
unhelpful advice so feel free to not
give good advice okay but hopeful voice
with bobbi compiler master casting right
now I know my Kaczynski just do that hey
guys is it cheating to go to an Asian
massage parlor that provides happy
ending if the guys in a relationship
kalila will you be okay Bobby went to
one Gilbert will you visit a rub-and-tug
and report to us so is it cheating to
get ahead guys you guys go first it 100%
is no no it's not that I would do that I
think there has to be a conversation
yeah it just says hey listen I'm you
know where I love you were making love
but if I go away for a couple of months
and I'm not gonna [ __ ] any random you
know no but if I went somewhere I got a
massage and she just flipped me over and
ripped me off real quick would that be a
bad thing she's like that's cheating all
right I you know I agree with you
because of the scale of things that
would hurt me that would hurt me the
least it's not that I and I'm asking you
to do it now but if it ever came to that
point where 10 years from now you just
want your [ __ ] balls drained we could
pound it out and I'd probably be okay
with it it's so it's such a business
transaction it's so unemotional it is
that to me you texting with a woman and
exchanging some you know you know some
type of flirtations is far more hurtful
than getting a [ __ ] rub and tug and
it has to be at a certain massage parlor
maybe of your choice yeah I mean I have
to pick the [ __ ] ogre who's gonna
yeah although I couldn't be like a
Russian massage parlor because no wait
that's vagina
yeah I don't think you'd be alright with
it I don't think that I mean I'm not I
mean I would have to have a conversation
I don't think you'd be alright with that
and III don't feel right with it because
it still is sexual and it still is with
somebody else for somebody like him it's
a little different because everything is
a gateway drug for him he the slightest
thing he might he might take the rub and
tub and that same day graduate to a
strip club get a [ __ ] and graduate to
a full addict he's an addict he doesn't
know how to stop at the little things
yeah I mean I when I do shows on the
road like you know I mean there are
sometimes situations where like I was I
got off the stage at Charlie good nights
and this drunk college kids so drunk
she just pulls me as I'm walking out she
does I'll blow you right now and I go
you know he didn't do that I did you
considered it no I would never totally
normally I would I didn't consider at
all I swear to God I mean that's why I'm
so comfortable telling it it's because
it was a nothing it was a nothing moment
but all that little if I just stopped
and I said tell me more you know that
all that stuff is crossing a line to me
I don't I've only gone to two in my life
by the rub and tugs yeah my friend I
went to Toronto wants to do a movie and
for my birthday he played it used to
play for the Blues and he's like hey got
your birthday present he came to visit
me I go okay and I had never you know
heard of Robin I just was naive Indiana
boy whatever and he took me this massage
place and I walked in and this blonde
woman goes I'm I need you to take a
shower shower and then I get there she
goes okay here's the deal
you can touch my breasts you can't touch
my [ __ ] and that's it I go that's
massage you ever and so she started
masseuse ah you know the worst massage
you ever I'm like all right but then she
whipped me over yeah and I remembered
this cuz it's only happened twice in my
life yeah I don't know what she sprayed
on me yes some Lube a but somebody got
in Mart on Mars yeah it was this is it
and then she bent my penis the opposite
way it's supposed to be not supposed to
aim
your face correct yeah she pulled it
like the other way the other way so it
hurt just a little inch window
ja ja ja ja it was like two streets
Chuck was a wine-bottle three yeah whoa
whoa I mean like that I was like oh yeah
and my buddy's like happy birthday buddy
oh my god I was like 25
[Music]